Hey, this is Jason with the Local
Locksmith Company. Today I'm making a
key for a 2018
Honda Accord. It's this key right here.
And I got this key
to add to it. This is from American Key
Supply. It's an OEM refurbished key.
Very good key. American Key Supply.
Reliable keys.
This key works. If you look at the
buttons, I'm going to press the button.
You can hear the locks.
This one doesn't. Nothing happens. So,
we're going to go in. We're using the um
auto propad and we're use auto G3 today
machine, but
I'm going to I had it out, so I'm going
to use it on this one. So, this is the
keyword programming. This one doesn't
work. And we're going to go to key
programming. Agree.
We're gonna go um
we probably need an internet signal.
So, we're gonna turn our mobile hotspot
on. We're going to watch up there for
our mobile hotspot to to take effect
right next to the battery display.
So, we're going to wait for that. We're
going to move on. We're just going to
keep an eye on it in the background and
we're going to go to Honda.
So, Honda right there
and then we're going to go.
Okay, let's get this set up right so
that we can work.
Okay, we're going to go by vehicle
and then we're going to go Accord is a
Honda Accord and it's a 13 to 19 Accord.
It's a 18 and it tells you if it'll do
it. Yes. Yes. Let's continue to
programming. So, it's a smart key.
Push start button. There's a button
right there.
It's 2022 or later. You need to connect
the device to the network. There it's
not. Okay.
Please turn on the ignition switch.
Press by starting hitting the stop start
button twice. So, one, two.
Okay. So, it's on.
Okay.
Can the ignition switch be turned on?
Yes.
Okay. It's in accessory mode, it tells
us.
Okay. It's connecting.
Okay. We're going to read the number of
read number of read red keys. Okay. Turn
this on the ignition switch.
Yes.
So, it's going to tell us how many keys
are on the car. There's two keys on the
car now. Okay. Now, we're going to add a
smart key. We're going to turn this
off right now.
We don't need the I think I might have
bumped it the programmer. Okay, we're
going to add a smart key.
Take all the smart keys out of the car
more than 2 meters away from the car.
Put one programmed smart key
in the car. Okay,
so okay, we got one program smart key in
the car. Turn on the ignition switch.
Press the stop start button twice. Can
the ignition switch be turned on? One.
Two. Okay.
Yes.
Okay. Configuring the system. Please
wait. Take the smart key out of the car.
More than 2 meters away. Put the the new
smart key into the car. Okay. So, hang
tight. I'm going to take this car key
out. I'll be right back.
One 2 me away.
Okay, I'm back.
All right, now
this new smart key is in the car.
Switch the ignition off within 5 15
seconds. So, we're going to go over and
we're going to switch the ignition off.
Switch the ignition on.
Okay, switch the ignition off.
Switch the ignition on. And again, you
have to hit the button twice to switch
the ignition on. Whether the security
light went off or on, the security light
is now off. I don't see it on there
anymore. It was a blinking light up
there. Yes, the security ignite is
extinguished.
Switch the ignition off.
Switch the ignition on within 15
seconds. Again, two times.
Okay.
Okay. Program success.
Okay. This is the new key.
Let's see if it works.
All right. It's working now. Let's start
it.
Starts the vehicle.
Security lights not on.
We're good to go.
And that's how easy it is. That's how
easy it is to program one of these Honda
keys. We'll push the start. And it's a
Honda key. Again, American Key Supply.
It's where I get these keys.
I don't want to go out and fail. That's
why I buy good keys. And you'll get good
keys from them.
again. We and we use the Propad Auto
Propad G3
Evolution.
And we made this job less than five
minutes long. All right, this has been
Jason with the Local Locksmith Company.
If you like the video, hit like. If you
want to see more, hit subscribe.
It's a 2018
Honda Accord. Push button start. Add a
key. And here's the key. This has been
Jason. Thanks for watching.